38 38
le 38 le 38e et la brigade canine
[Rires]
moi ça va comment tu t'appelles sur ta
guise et l'attention par rock et blues
j'aime bien c'est une foufoune rouge ça
m'a pas dit mais ça va merci d'être là
beaufort vous êtes magnifique attention
avec les boules parce que là qu'en fait
vous allez être papa dans d'autres méga
fan je sais j'ai l'oeil pour ça j'ai me
directe faite et j'en passe
venez venez prénois ça passera glissait
j'allais être papa dans deux mois frank
g des fiches sur tout le monde râle
public vous êtes un jeune chômeur de 20
ans c'est ça ouais votre copine
s'appelle newman elle accouche donc dans
deux mois j'offre ce téléphone téléphone
peut l'ouvrir
tu peux ouvrir ce téléphone baazi voilà
voilà
et ça qu on est est ce que c'est ça que
tu voulais
j'ai commencé doucement des cazelles
bonjour qui est cassé
[Applaudissements]
le téléphone est cassé est ce que mes
copains cédér louis voilà tu serais pas
resté là
j'aimerais bien mais je peux pas tu
saurais pas le réparer le téléphone
pourquoi parce qu'en fait à pas les
outils la voilà je pas les outils et
j'allais faire un tas pour pouvoir
réparer les téléphones as-tu fait une
formation pour réparer les téléphones et
ben voila j'ai pas les moyens de payer
la formation fait je peux pas travailler
la formation bon est-ce qu'on a une
certaine agathe parmi nous agathe est ce
qu a gâté la agathe à agathe
[Applaudissements]
à gaillon douilles
l'egypte était bien théorie vous êtes
vous voulez faire une formation dans les
téléphones
ouais c'est ça et vous henry je crois
que tu es donc directeur commercial chez
mobile store france d'accord qui propose
de former des personnes arrêtées
relations stables et les formes et aussi
à la gestion de points de vente et de
vente ce que la formation écoute qu'elle
coûte combien
un coût de 5000 euros c'est 1 0 a donné
et bah quoi donc tu en train de me dire
tu le prends en formation prend direct
[Applaudissements]
ses pairs tu vois la formation donc tu
vas pouvoir réparer les téléphones
étaient contents oui mais j'aime bien la
formation samba
ouais franchement mais lui je sens bien
une chanson qu'il a un truc je sens
qu'un truc et à l'enfant car et tout ça
j'ai envie de plus pour lui j'ai envie
de plus en plus je peux faire il je
pense qu'un gars tu as quelque chose de
plus pour lui agathe à la fin de la
façon dont vous pouvez voir votre propre
boutique franchisée mobile / france et
nous vous l'offrons pour une valeur de
son et l'euro
[Applaudissements]
toi
nous pouvons
alors
là le magasin à tous
[Applaudissements]
les scieries voilà et basse énorme
chérie ça c'est vous le dis je c'est un
cadeau exceptionnel d'accessoires et
franchement c'est du jamais vu
je pense à la télé vous voulez
absolument offrir on a été touchée aussi
par contre témoignage et moi ce que
j'aimerais tu vois c'est que là tu va
démarrer la boutique quatre ans c'est
toujours une galère mais non express ya
pas de bourgois là tu vois tu vas devoir
démarrer tout ça donc j'aimerais te
trouver des clients
donc ce que j'aimerais qu'on classe au
téléphone c'est ce que j'aimerais moi
j'ai envie on est déjà 105 mille ans
j'ai envie qu est-ce qu à le faire j'ai
envie d'offrir un smartphone et un
forfait à tout le public
[Applaudissements]